Ryan your favorite holiday is this week
sweetest day nope um Columbus Day nope
Martin Luther King jr. Day no keep going
um oh my goodness just think can't think
of any of my other favorite holidays
just think conspicuous consumption oh my
god
you mean Black Friday that's my favorite
holiday man I remember when we we worked
in the corporate world and we worked in
retail and and we had to just we had to
get up at 2 a.m. because all of our
stores had to prepare we had to go pass
out flyers and analyst and coffee try to
try to woo them into buying our product
and when you say whoo you mean coerce
yes yeah no I was wooing a man lady you
would buy a cell phone what's up
handsome you needed some high-speed
Internet oh my goodness yeah so
thankfully one have to deal with that
anymore in fact because the most chaotic
day of the year is right around the
corner Ryan and I recorded two
meditations for you to anti-consumerism
meditations one it's about 12 to 15
minutes long it's a longer meditation
and one is a two-minute meditation
before you decide to buy something it's
a pausing before you buy and maybe this
will help you out on Black Friday it'll
help you out the rest of the year as
well we did it for our friend Dan Harris
he has a great book called 10% happier
but he just started this meditation app
called the 10% happier app Sean if you
can put a link to that in the show notes
for us it's here's what I'll tell you if
we don't get paid by him to do any of
this we did it as a favor to him but
also to help our folks who want some
guided meditation away from consuming
and of course being more deliberate with
the things we do decide to consume and
so if you want that Black Friday
meditation you can find that in our show
notes you can just find a link to the
app there and I think we'll put one of
them on our patreon account as well for
all of our patreon supporters all right
let's go ahead and dive into this
episode we were in Denver for this and
what a crowd that was I mean they were
literally
ending like I mean it was and it was
unbelievable yeah this is just a great
theater great crowd great people Thank
You Denver can't wait to get back
whenever that is
all right Joe we'll we'll see you soon
enjoy
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'd
be fine without him live from the gothic
theater my name is Joshua fields Milburn
and I am Ryan Nicodemus and we are live
in Denver
[Applause]
I remember our first tour stop in Denver
it was December of 2011 and was one of
our bigger tour stops seven people were
there and now we can get you know
something like 700 people crammed into a
room so thank you so much for that thank
you for being here
you should we take phone calls but
instead of pulling out your phone right
now you're welcome to step on up to this
mic we'd love to answer your questions
we brought a bag of answers I have a
question go for it how does your hair
look so amazing what kind of product do
you use
well don't worry to find that out you
have to support us on patreon that's all
right if that's all my hair care videos
are I have a vlog on the side I guess it
looks like we've answered all the
questions judge this is gonna be the
this is truly gonna be a minimalist
podcast what's up brother what's your
name I'm bald
no that's and what boy I didn't see that
on the pot and why does they call you
that no no no I my name is Brian I'm
from the Midwest well poor and actually
from Nebraska nice we drove in today so
welcome thank you so much central
Nebraska area but anyway been listening
to you guys for a while really
appreciate what you do and the fact that
you're encouraging folks to live a more
intentional life one question I have for
you in our lives we we we deal with a
lot of stuff emotionally we deal with a
lot of addictions compulsions things
like that and when you're trying to make
that transition into being more
intentional and and
and directive in your life and the
things you want to do when you start
making those choices what advice do you
have to make sure you don't fall off the
sparsity you know yeah so I think that
you will fall off I mean that's the the
bad news and maybe the the sort of
relieving news as well like Ryan earlier
talked about it's not going to be
perfect and during his talk and I think
for me like just the other day and
here's a good example so Ryan and I for
a few months probably three or four
months removed all the social media apps
from our phones as an experiment we
first started this tour and it was great
but also like that addictions there
right so I felt like for the first week
two weeks like I go twitching for it I
go looking for the app that didn't exist
anymore and I think we do that with a
lot of our our our stuff as well yeah we
try to buy things because that's what
we're supposed to do and I would catch
myself reaching for the phone and going
for the app not even knowing that I was
doing it was a total impulse right and
so we removed it and I totally reset the
impulse and then I'm in my hotel room in
Salt Lake City two days ago and I just
caught myself like scrolling through my
Twitter feed and I what the [ __ ] are you
doing and I think we often go back and
so the problem isn't the crash the the
or if the problem is the crash then the
solution is the course correction and
noticing the crash as soon as possible
or even better if you can anticipate it
before it happens in course correct then
that's even better and so for me the
answer isn't about avoiding all
stumblings it's about course correcting
as soon as possible yeah I will echo
what Josh said I have news for you and
everyone else in here you're all gonna
fail before you die yeah I know but now
you're ready for it dude yeah
but but no seriously I mean I don't ever
look at being one of the minimalists
which by the way we we are the
minimalists because the domain was
available for like seven bucks so even
me being one of minimalist men every
time that like oh man that sexy new
iPhone came out that mine's like four
generations old and like my first my
first impulse was like I'm gonna get
that I'm gonna get that iPhone a he
still has no role I thought iPhone tends
a little out of my budget but I'm like
iPhone ain't like maybe I should look
into that it's got like a better camera
on there like better stability so forth
and so on
but then what I would I have instilled
in my life over the last several years
is like before I'm gonna spend over a
hundred bucks
I will wait I will wait a little bit a
week at least to like really look at
okay what's this phone gonna do for me
and when I really look into it didn't
take me a week who's like you know 10
minutes of like you know like I don't
know what I'm gonna do more with this
phone than what I have now and it is
instilling habits like that that will
help you to fail as little as possible
you know I wrote this this essay about
more wins than losses and I write about
how I used to be a just a lot of bits
not very proud of who my 25 year old
self was I'll just say that and I used
to looking back I would lose all the
time and when I when I say lose it's I
go out to the bar and run up a $3 bar
tab
I go out and spend you know a couple
grand a month on narcotics I mean I
would really do some really shitty stuff
and now in my life it's not about never
losing as much as like having as little
losses as possible with with both myself
and when and you said addiction which
really stands out to me because when we
say addiction that is usually a
pejorative in fact like the clinical
definition of addiction is a pejorative
I mean someone who needs help
essentially but you know Josh and I we
kind of like to puts put little phrases
and words and kind of flip them on their
head and now when I think about
addiction it's like I still have
addictions but it's like what are the
good things I'm addicted to so my old
life it was work work work work work oh
great I'm off work like who what what
drugs do I want to do or what you know
what pacifier do I want to use like I'm
gonna those are the people I'm gonna
call in them will go you know we'll go
do or pacifying things and and what the
problem with that is is that it was work
pacifying getting up rinse repeat
and then the weekends it was just you
know a longer a longer period to do that
stuff to pacify myself but but now what
I realized is that if I continue that
type of behavior like I don't have time
to focus on my health so now like I you
know Mariah and I we will go to the gym
for you know half hour 45 minutes five
out of seven days a week if I was living
that old lifestyle there's no way I
could have done that so by incorporating
like that good habit into my life by
default I had to say no to other things
so I could say yes to two you know just
a regular workout routine so you know
there is no magic answer here but you
know if there's something that that you
know is standing out in your life for
anyone else here that you know you have
to change like to start with have one
thing and really start incorporating a
good habit to overtake that bad habit or
you know find an accountability partner
to help you overcome that bad habit
whatever it may be but having good
people in your life and having good
habits that will help you lose as little
as possible but you're still gonna fail
sometimes I just want to be clear on
that
have you read our book everything that
remains no I don't want to sell you a
copy so I'd love to give you a copy
Jessica if you're around here somewhere
and you could give them a copy because
it talks a lot of thank you it talks a
lot about we talked about in that book
sort of that transition of bad habits to
better habits
and moving from bad problems to better
problems as well but we're still gonna
have them awesome thanks so much you
guys want to reduce the clutter in your
shower stall with hair products I'll
leave my number with you during the hug
round okay
thanks Brian thanks brother appreciate
him head my name is Harry Harry for
those that are listening I have a lot of
hair how for contrast how dare you out
beard me it's sad is the winter beard um
I'm trying to draw it out were you from
brother I'm from Alabama
welcome awesome wow transplant yeah cool
ah I'm gonna say it roll tide don't hate
me
oh wow are you serious - what sequester
brother but so my question is about
passion so I'm from the south
cultural influence for me growing up
what you do is what you do and your
passions were outside of that they were
always divided so it's more about
identifying your strengths and
maximizing your potential in that you
all said something earlier about
passions what do I
I couldn't even list that for you now my
wife and I have been on our journey for
three years got out of dad can I ask you
a question
horse weight congratu-fucking-lations
for getting out of debt dude that is
awesome I'm telling you that is the new
American dream like that is how good
does that feel dude dude quarter a
million dollars test oh my god Wow
you know I I think when the passion
question comes up one of the things that
prevents us from from doing things that
we're passionate about or seeking out a
passion is because we feel tethered to a
lifestyle that is contingent on paying
down debt that we rarely ever pay down
and so we just get stuck on that cycle
and so you're in a really good place to
start ask us some questions right now a
couple questions that that I find are
helpful when when we're trying to figure
out like what am i passionate about the
the first one is like what do you enjoy
doing what your hobbies that kind of
thing and that's an obvious question the
other question is what pisses you off
and I find that so often people find
what they're passionate about but by
sort of being pissed off by something
else it's sort of out there in the
zeitgeist I mean it can be it could be
something that's political or so sure
environmental or I mean with with me and
Ryan it was like I am pissed off about
the fact that I'm I'm stuck on this I'm
stuck in this rat race and I was really
good at it so I would win quite often
but when you win the rat race you're
still a rat and and all right that
pissed me off and I wanted to do
something about it and ultimately we
were able to and so it wasn't so much
about like what I love doing which for
me is writing I loved writing fiction I
was able to sort of combine the two
something I loved doing was something to
piss me off and and that's what sort of
energized me the thing that I'll say
though is we too often confuse
excitement for passion
we're get really excited about an idea
or a a story or or a product or
something or like I really love this I'm
passionate about it and for me it was
like writing I'd get this this idea for
a novel or a short story and then some
of my 20s I would start working on it
for a day or two days or a week and I'd
be excited and eventually I'd hit a wall
and say well [ __ ] I'm not passionate
about this
because I'm not excited about it anymore
I think real passion comes from drudging
through the drudgery being willing to
put in the effort in the work and being
pissed off and wanting to put your head
through a wall the real payoff the real
passion comes from the other side of
that yeah the only thing I would add to
that is in Western society we have this
this very common like idiom we hear of
if you find something you love and you
do it you never have to work a day in
your life
[ __ ] now there's probably someone
here or someone listening to this who is
like no no like I do it I wake up every
morning and it's puppy dogs and rainbows
and it's awesome and that's great like I
really envy people like that but the
fact is is like I do I live in the dream
and like I really you know it for all
intents and purposes like I'm living my
dream we work our ass off so that's the
only caveat I would throw in there is
that things that you you devote time to
that that you're interested in you're
trying to develop a passion don't ever
think for a second that just because you
feel like you're working you're not
passionate about it for me what it comes
down to is like what is that net gain
like or net loss if it's a net loss then
there's a certain point where I'm gonna
I'm gonna cut my losses and move on to
something else but at the end of the day
it's like this is by far I mean the the
the flights and then getting up early I
mean it was it's crazy like doing all
these traveling but it's so worth the
work and like being here with you and
all of you that is like by far the most
positive thing I could get out of this
so for me like I continue to do it so I
would yes Drudge for the drudgery I
think every actual question though I was
stepping on what's her he had an actual
question that I stepped on oh we haven't
gotten to his question yet
well I forget what I was gonna say
anyway all right please ask your
question
Harry Harry no Harry Harry you say yeah
I was just continuing the joke dude that
was a test
thanks man yeah no I think you're
touching on my question because
essentially you know the work and we're
no strangers to work that doesn't scare
me but it's more about that I mean
because as humans we we are designed to
work I mean we we get a lot of
fulfillment out of work it's a part of
our life but so we're kind of in this
phase where we can pursue things that
interest us you know because we aren't
tied down to things so I'm kind of in
this space where it's like well I'm good
at these things but what am I really
passionate about can I marry these
things in my life or do I need to be a
barista so I have time to pursue those
things right original thought very Yeah
right exactly there's a barista shortage
in Denver yeah you know what the the
thing that you're talking about there is
is being so two things one is being
interested in something is important
because you can be really good at
something and never be passionate about
it I was the director of operations for
a hundred and fifty retail stores which
just makes my jaw go numb whenever I say
that now and I was really good at it I
was better at that than I am at this but
I didn't I wasn't interested in it I
wasn't passionate about it in fact the
important part it didn't align with my
values and so our interests in order for
them to become passions they need to
align with our values I think I think
passion is one-half love and one-half
obsession and so find something you can
get healthfully obsessed with and and
work your ass off at it man the only
thing I warned
is when you take something you're
interested in or let's say you have
something you're passionate about and
you and you like try to make that a
money driver that is a really surefire
way to kill that passion sure because at
the end of the day like you're not gonna
wake up the next morning and want to do
it you have to do it and that that's a
little bit dangerous so you don't
necessarily have to marry the two you
people laughed at the barista joke or at
your briefs to comment um I don't know
if that was a joke or not but people
laughed
no cuz Josh and I say that all the time
but at the end of the day if I had to
pick a like regular professional like
okay what can I do that's gonna pay the
bills and work you like give me as much
free time as possible so I can do the
things that I was actually passionate
about so there's a couple of different
angles to approach it thank you
attention to say one thing just
celebrates you guys y'all's catchphrase
about not using people that is so
rampant in our society I think it's
great so I really appreciate you all we
appreciate you man thank you so much man
have a good
alright one sec before we move on if
you're listening to this at home and you
have a comment or tip for anyone who
asks a question today give us a call
leave us a comment at four zero six two
one nine seven eight three nine or you
can send a voice memo right from your
phone to podcast at the minimalists
dot-com usually write it down first and
makes it more concise and and it gives
you a much better chance of being on the
show it's my favorite part of the show
by the way is when we stop talking at
the very end of the show and Shawn will
put out like a handful of these these
comments and I learn a whole lot much of
which I steal and incorporate back into
my act Ryan do you know what time it is
I really wish I had like a pocket watch
to pull out you put a monocle in yes uh
man it is time for our hashtag ask the
minimalist lightening round where we
usually answer questions from social
media but it'd be really weird if you're
looking at Twitter on our phones up here
on stage I might catch me doing it that
you could just I could just
automatically start scrolling and not
realize I'm doing it yeah so what does
like answer you guys questions in line
yeah yeah that's probably better but so
what we'll do is we try to give you a
pithy short shareable less than 140
character response that that you can
live tweet or whatever by the way
Jessica who runs our social media she's
around here she live tweets from the
event hashtag glasses now he's lurking
in the shadows anyway so what we try to
do is wrap it up with a pretty little
bow but we monitor on a little bit there
she is ladies and gentlemen Jessica
Williams
we're on Instagram Twitter and Facebook
at the minimalists and she curates a lot
of what we do there we still interact on
social media but she is what she's the
person who makes it beautiful so thank
you Jess and so we will monitor on we'll
come up with an answer and then we'll
tie it up with a pretty little bow or
maybe an ugly bow what's your name say
thank you so much for everything you
guys have done you've changed my life
have listened to every single podcast
episode I'm honored to be here tonight
my heart is like something on in my
chest right now because I've always
wanted to be at the microphone so thank
you that is awesome my my question is in
what areas of your life have you taken
minimalism maybe too far
define yeah so define too far what do
you mean by that well I want to ask you
that and say you know in what areas or
categories of your life have you taken
minimalism to a point where maybe you
wish you haven't you didn't do that I
think that's really been the nice thing
about minimalism for me it's been a
series of sort of stoical experiments
over time and so I've had the
opportunity to temporarily deprive
myself because minimalism is not about
deprivation minimalism is about living
intentionally that's my pit the answer
as tweetable right Jess by the way we're
calling these minimal Maxim's just set
up this little side website for it's
called minimal Maxim's calm and it's
like the hundreds of our little
shareable answers all it's just one at a
time people set it up is there they're
like home page on their browser and you
get some random quote many of which
might be inspiring
results may vary but we the good news
about this is it isn't it isn't about
like perpetual deprivation and it's not
about living a life where I'm suffering
right I think it's ok with to experience
pain from time to time I think it's
helpful I think it's necessary to
experience pain and it's an it's
inevitable it's unavoidable the
suffering however is a choice and so I
will temporarily remove things from my
life knowing that if I decide to bring
it back into my life I will bring it
back in more intentionally and so the
honest answer is I will go too far all
the time to test my limits and sometimes
move that line but the good news is if I
find that I'm depriving myself then I
can always bring it back into my life
that's my pithy answer that's good um
god I wish I had a sexy answer for this
like I just don't uh one without and
Mariah and I we went without internet
for a while when we were living together
then she started like doing coding
school online
she's like Ryan I don't want to have to
go to a coffee shop every time I have to
like do this six hours worth of coding
so we have internet now such a hypocrite
Shawn edit that out know at that you
know that seriously would that was a
great tweetable line I will just I'm
totally gonna steal Millie's line and
that anything that I take out of my life
if it makes me feel deprived I will
always be able to bring it back into my
life thank you howdy
Thomas I'm Andrew and I'm the Denver
lead up group so for the people who
don't know with Josh and I back in 2014
we went on the road we did a 100 city
tour and this was like that was our
third tour I think at the time maybe
three or four yeah third or fourth and
every time we would go out on the road
people will come up to us after the show
and they're like man really loved
hearing you guys thanks for the hug
there's some really awesome people here
like how how can i connect with these
people and Josh and I never really had a
good answer to that like people would
ask us and you know I would say like I
don't know do you have Facebook have you
tried tinder yeah like you're an adult
go ask for that person's number if you
think they're cool they um it just
wasn't a good answer so in 2014 when
Josh and I went out on that 100 city
tour what we wanted to have a good
answer for that so we started this thing
called minimalist org where there are
essentially 100 communities around the
world where people like I'm sorry what's
your name dude
Andrew Andrew where people like Andrew
they will lead meet up groups in major
cities so chances are like if you live
in the United States there's probably a
group within two to four hours from work
good chance yeah but but uh but yeah
basically minimalist letters where
people get together and every single
city is different and that's what I love
about it it's like Josh and I don't have
any template we have Andrew like Andrew
does this on his own by himself he makes
it happen we don't tell him what to do
so how do those groups go man like tell
us a little about the
yeah yeah so we get about between 15 and
20 each time yeah and I started you'll
have more after tonight yeah yeah that's
that's actually put I'm kind of scared
of like ah crap I need a venue like this
um but no I've been leading it since
February 2016 it's been a lot of fun I
keep it really chill and relaxed and
that's who Denver is just all chill and
relax so yeah it's just the just simple
get-together yeah so if you like to
chill and or if you like to relax go
hang out with Andrew all right man
what's your question dude yeah so I
guess as a leader kind of ties into that
I feel since I'm the face of the
minimalist like group in Denver I feel
like I'm failing and I feel like I'm not
you know and so the first is because of
the hair no
which is hair oh yeah cuz well okay it
is very soft you need to when I swipe
right on tinder people know trust me
it's good it's good enough it's good
enough I'm okay on the hair part sorry
brother
alright q go why do you feel like you
fail dude okay
so for me I always treated like a
therapy session so I asked a ton of
questions to the other people and I feel
like oh man I'm not as good as all my
followers essentially all the people
that you know come to the meetups and
talk a bunch and have a great time and I
just feel I feel like I'm not doing my
part as the leader of the group and so
for me my question is how do you respect
yourself and how do you keep loving
yourself through that failure and saying
that what I'm doing is good enough
I think I think so my pithy answer and
I'll try to unpack this I picked the
answer is lower your expectations but
raise your standards and thanks I think
that quite often we are so disappointed
we feel like we're failing when we're
not because we have this pie-in-the-sky
expectation and our standards were too
low but if you lower that expectation
and you have a high standard you show up
and you know you're gonna give it your
best given the resources that you have
your time your attention by the way
questions are the best way for you to
grow it's also the best way for you to
engage with other people asking
questions is far more important than you
just get up getting up there and
bloviating to a group of 20 people right
and that's why we're here now I write
and I give a talk at the beginning that
you know we we wrote down and and we've
practiced but after that we're here to
interact and we answer questions but
you'll notice that we also ask questions
along the way because that's how we
learn as well because you'll you'll
you'll see something and you think it's
you'll think it's one way I was walking
to get something to eat earlier at Park
burger and yeah it was awesome and I as
I was walking there I looked over and
there was an avocado on someone's rear
view mirror that's Denver for you
and it's just probably more of a
Californian thing actually but I looked
at that and I was just sort of wondering
like what is the story behind that right
and the sad part about that is there
wasn't anyone I could ask the question
of and so my mind starts making up all
of these stories like maybe someone
borrowed an avocado and their friend
wasn't home so they left it on their
rearview mirror happens all the time and
and I think I think we feel a lot better
when we're able to ask those questions
the only thing I'll leave you with is
keep asking better questions if you ask
better quality questions you're gonna
get better answers yeah Andrew you're
doing awesome dude I mean I have like
removed myself from Facebook you know
Josh how do you know someone left
Facebook don't worry he'll tell you
so jess has really been the one who is
like really been spearheading minimalist
org and I know that you're doing an
awesome job because I don't get emails
from Jessica like hey this community
leaders not doing an awesome job so no
you're doing great man if people are
showing up and you're creating some
stimulating conversation like that's
that's the most you can give you know to
that to that community man I guess if I
was to give you a pithy answer it would
be something like if you feel like you
are asking too many questions sometimes
we do need to talk less and listen more
thank you very much guys all right
before we hop on to our next question
here we're gonna move on real quick to
right here right now so we talked about
what's going on in the lives of the
minimalists so yeah we're gonna be on
tour a rest of this year and then and
then in the spring in Australia New
Zealand les is now calm but then also
this is where we talk about all of our
sponsors Ryan this episode is brought to
you by Josh what but have you been
finding trouble sleeping at night
actually are you having trouble getting
a close shave clearly how many times do
you have to pick the underwear out from
your crack each day I'm just having
trouble with my style if there was just
like the service that would put it in a
box for me and send it to me regularly
I've got good news for you Ryan how I
need to build a website mmm you're gonna
be pleased to know that this episode is
brought to you by nobody
why because advertisements
[Applause]
yeah you're damn right they do all right
you a quick interruption if you want to
listen to our bonus episode this week as
well as all of our past bonus episodes
head on over to the minimalists dot-com
and click donate at the top of our
website
each week we publish the minimalists
private podcast exclusively for our
patreon supporters this private podcast
shows up in your normal podcast feed
like Apple podcasts overcast Google Play
or whatever podcast app you use and it
shows up right next to our normal weekly
podcast you know the one you're
listening to right now and being a
patreon supporter also gets you first
access to the best tickets to all of our
live events as well as access to our
monthly private livestream video which
is called ask the minimalists anything
it's worth noting that none of this
money goes to me or to Ryan instead
we're using your contributions to build
a new podcast in film studio in Los
Angeles so that we can create more
meaningful audio and video creations if
you already support this podcast thank
you I know that $2 often doesn't sound
like a lot of money I mean it's less
than a cup of coffee but it is your
support that keeps this podcast 100%
advertisement free because
advertisements suck and if we can just
get 2% of our audience to support this
show then we'll have enough funds to
produce some amazing new creations your
support is truly appreciated all right
Joe back to the regular show Sean can
you fade back to the regular podcast I
was getting the the lights dimmed on us
that I'm being told that we're being
kicked off the stage but before we wrap
it up I just want to thank a few people
we're on the road right now with a tour
manager road manager tour bus driver
podcast producer podcast editor book
editor all in one person
ladies and gentlemen podcast Sean hiding
in the shadows way up there
[Applause]
thanks for making it look easy Shawn
dude send me earlier they're like having
their like hey what do you think about
the lights I'm like Shawn's
he's opinion number one Jessica's
opinion number two and I am third on the
list I was taking a nap but no sir
without Shawn like this we would not
look nearly as beautiful so thanks Shawn
or sound nearly as beautiful all right
Joe I was gonna land better all right so
uh one other person actually two other
people to think well I think I want to
thank the Gothic theater for having us
here tonight let's give them round of
applause great venue great staff and
some great people especially the people
sitting in these chairs tonight last
person I want to thank here tonight as
you you paid some money to get in here
we're really grateful for that allows us
to pay for security and lights and sound
and the microphones and for travel and
for hotel rooms we used to actually
sleep on readers floors for several
years of touring and now we're just
really grateful to have a bed to sleep
in tonight and you gave up your two most
precious resources though it wasn't just
your money it was your time and your
attention and we're really grateful for
that and if you all leave here tonight
with just one message we hope it's this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works
thanks for being here yo thank you so
much Denver you guys are awesome
all right Ryan before we dive in to all
of these listener comments as I've said
this is my favorite part of the show we
get to listen to other people's ideas
instead of just me and you rambling
incessantly yeah I want to remember I
want to remind people to not purchase
the bag that we made yes if you think
you need a bag first listen to the
two-minute meditation right that's
actually a good idea so if they listen
to ten person half of your meditation
maybe they'll it'll stop them from
buying this bag from buying the bag yes
and this isn't a weird like reverse
psychology thing either like we
legitimately have made the bag because
we think it will be Valatie product we
made it for some people but it's not for
most people expect it it's for very few
people I mean honestly I'm the whole
scope of the people who are going to
have access to this bag you know at the
end of the day like Josh and I we know
that there's a need for it we're
fulfilling that need but chances are you
probably don't need it yes you he's
talking to you specifically but we did
start an IndieGoGo campaign to figure
out how many of these bags that we need
to make so if you're interested in
finding out more you can just go to the
minimalists comm slash bag you can find
all the information you can see the
video we made and then you can also read
more and what we'll talk about why the
other reasons you maybe we should put
together the top ten reasons you
shouldn't buy this bag that's that's
that's a really good idea all right
we'll have to give that a shot maybe if
you're on our email list that'll show up
in your inbox anyway while we're on the
topic of what we're doing we are
traveling and in fact we're going to be
in New Zealand and Australia next year
in in March and man those tickets are
going crazy fast but for whatever reason
the the folks down under absolutely love
us and we're really grateful for that
and so some of those events might
already be sold out by the time this
episode comes out but you can find all
the tickets over the minimalists comm
and we have three more tour stops in
north america we're going to be in
Detroit Milwaukee and Las Vegas the Las
Vegas event is a charity event it's the
House of Blues January 14th
100% of the profits from that's a
regular vens when I say charity events
just a regular event we're still doing
our podcast and a talk but 100 percent
of the profits are gonna go to the Las
Vegas Victims Fund so we can help out
the folks who were negatively affected
by by that horrible shooting the the
mass shooting that happened just
recently so come on out the minimalists
calm if you get a chance to see us and
it allows us to do something good and
contribute in a meaningful way in the
process
all right let's dive into these listen
their comments and tips from well from
you hello Josh and Ryan my name is
Melissa Hollingsworth I'm actually from
Dayton Ohio and I personally say enjoy
your podcast I listen to it mainly while
I work out I wanted to bride input to
the question that brandy had invaded Las
Vegas regarding her yearbooks her
hometown library may also accept her
yearbooks where I live in Dayton and
they just recently rebuilt the downtown
metro library they're actually building
a database for all the local yearbooks
just to provide an example hello I am
Colleen and I am from the Netherlands
recently I heard a podcast and there was
about given presence or receiving
presence and I wanted to share some nice
ideas about that so every year it's
normal with your birthday that you ask
for presents but if you say no I don't
want to have anything people still come
up with stuff and so this year I tried
to ask everyone for one flower a picked
flower or a bought flower didn't matter
just one flower so at the end of the
evening I had one bouquet of beautiful
flowers and it was very nice because
everyone was talking about how nice the
bouquet was so we really added some
value to the evening as well and other
ideas I haven't tried them yet but I
also wanted to try maybe next year to
ask people to give food that I would
donate to well we called the food bank
or I could in Holland is very common
that you make an online list where you
put on the things that you want to have
and I was thinking about instead of
putting things on the list I would write
down things like a smile or a compliment
or a good story or a funny joke or
something like that so that would be
their present for the evening and the
thing that would be a nice idea to try
out and then for when it comes to giving
gifts I have a few friends that also
said I don't want anything
and now for three times in a row I've
succeeded in actually not giving
something because they asked for nothing
and it's interesting because it did make
me feel very uncomfortable and because
it's in our culture to give something so
but they didn't they said I don't want
anything so I didn't gave them anything
I just gave them my company and in the
end it felt good so I think if someone
really asks for nothing then just don't
give anything just give your company or
a smile or otherwise just give a nice
flower
everyone gets happy from a nice flower
hi dr. Ryan
my name is Nene and I'm from England and
mother's gonna die living in Hydra at
the moment and then I've got a minimum
of the fifth as well
for people that are like me much like to
have really long showers but a trying
serum use less water to protect the
environment and to save money and so
yeah hazards look for the one strong
shower so I load up a film on my parents
I really love that yeah looming around
three minute marks and they're talking
about sticking around for during another
and then arises showers for the length
of that song and I'm not practicing
since though some public Christ that was
a second some ones that I really hate
and so yeah if I hadn't got out of the
shower by just defining first on the day
but then I really have to be out
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your green oh I bet that you'll be fine
without every little thing that you got
a hand
every little thing that you got you
gotta reach for and you gotta grab oh I
bet that you be fine
without your team
[Music]
you